BILL: SIXTH IN THE NBA IN
SCORING, ONE SPOT AHEAD OF HIS
TEAMMATE, ZACH LAVINE AND HE IS
PROUD OF BEING THE ALL-TIME
LEADER FOR THE TORONTO FRANCHISE
AND GAMES AND MINUTES.
IT MEANT A LOT TO HIM TO PLAY
THAT MUCH AND THAT WELL FOR
TORONTO.
A.D. FALLS DOWN.
TURNOVER.
HE LOST HIS FOOTING AS HE CAME
DOWN TO EARTH.
AND HE LOST HIS SHOE.
STU: I DON'T UNDERSTAND HOW YOU
CAN LOSE YOUR SHOE.
THEY DON'T STRAP THEM ON VERY
TIGHT.
BILL: A.D. HAS BEEN TOSSED!
HE IS OUT OF THE GAME!
THEY LET THEM PLAY ON BEFORE
A.D. COULD GET HIS SHOE ON AND
HE GOT UPSET.
THE HEAVE-HO.
STU: HE ALREADY HAD ONE
TECHNICAL.
WITH THE SECOND TECHNICAL, IT IS
AN EARLY SHOWER.
BILL: A TECHNICAL FOUL WHICH
MEANS TWO T'S AND YOU ARE GONE.
20 POINTS.
THAT WAS AN EMPHATIC HEAVE-
HO FROM THE OFFICIAL.
STU: THE CHOICE OF VERBIAGE MUST
HAVE BEEN NICE.
BILL: THAT WAS EMPHATIC.
87-66.
STU: HE IS TRYING TO PUT ON HIS
SHOE BUT WE CANNOT SEE WHAT HIS
LIPS ARE SAYING.
[LAUGHTER]
BILL: ALL RIGHT.
DERRICK JONES JR., HE ATTACKS.
YET ANOTHER, HIS THIRD
THREE-POINT OPPORTUNITY OF THE
QUARTER?
I BELIEVE THAT IS RIGHT.
DERRICK JONES JR., ANOTHER
AND-ONE.
89-66.
THAT IS THE SECOND EJECTION, BY
THE WAY, FOR ANTHONY DAVIS IN
HIS CAREER.
A.D. AND HIS 10TH YEAR -- A.D.